Ірландський лоукостер Ryanair, приходу якого так довго чекали українці,
нарешті здійснив свій перший рейс в Україну за напрямком Берлін-Київ.
Українці радіють, адже ірландська авіакомпанія
вважається найдешевшим лоукостером.
Та яка насправді ціна дешевих авіаперевезень від Ryanair?
Останнім часом Ryanair переживає
найбільшу в історії компанії хвилю страйків.
Лише в червні цього року через це було скасовано понад 1000 рейсів.
Сотні тисяч пасажирів в аеропортах
стали заручниками протестів пілотів авіакомпанії.
Ті вже тривалий час скаржаться на низьку зарплатню й ганебні умови праці.
Надто щільні графіки перельотів та порівняно мізерні зарплати -
це ціна дешевих квитків від Ryanair.
Майже всі літаки бюджетного перевізника - економ-класу.
Це означає малий простір для ніг, незручні крісла, відсутність ковдр, якщо холодно, тощо.
Для короткого перельоту можна потерпіти,
але для довгих терпіння може забракнути.
Їжа і напої не входять до ціни квитка.
За все, навіть за просту воду, доведеться платити додатково.
І ціна там зовсім не "лоукост". Приміром,
сендвіч із кавою на борту коштує близько 300 гривень.
Лише за цей рік Ryanair уже кілька разів міняв умови перевезення багажу.
Раніше можна було брати дві сумки:
валізу здати безкоштовно в багажний відсік,
а невелику ручну поклажу взяти із собою в салон.
Тепер безкоштовно можна брали лише маленьку сумку,
а за валізу - додатково платити 180 або 240 гривень.
Якщо раніше під час бронювання двох або більше квитків
система лоукостера автоматично розподіляла місця пасажирів поруч,
то тепер такої гарантії більше немає і ви можете опинитися в різних кінцях літака.
Так авіакомпанія змушує бронювати місця, доплачуючи від 120 гривень.
Якщо ж пасажири намагаються помінятися місцями вже в літаку,
аби сидіти поруч, то стюардеси можуть заборонити це.
Бюджетні авіакомпанії часто базуються
у віддалених та незручних аеропортах, приміром,
Франкфурт-Хан чи Ейдховен, відстань від яких до самого міста - більше 100 кілометрів.
Не набагато краща ситуація з аеропортами Барселона-Жирона чи Венеція-Тревізо.
Трансфер від таких летовищ може коштувати
додаткових 400-600 гривень в один бік та тривати довше самого перельоту.